Republican Georgia Senate candidate
Herschel Walker's son
has now brutally turned on him and is
denouncing Herschel Walker on the same
day that a woman has come forward and
said
pro-life Herschel Walker impregnated me
urged me to get an abortion and then
paid for the abortion we already talked
about that here is Christian Walker a
sort of known influencer in fact the I
guess he's called the legitimate son of
Herschel Walker I don't really like that
term because it you're not illegitimate
just because your dad doesn't want
anything to do with you but anyway he's
called the legitimate son of Herschel
Walker and he has had enough of Herschel
Walker he's had enough of his own dad
even though Herschel Walker is a mega
nut and Christian Walker is a mega nut
Christian Walker tweeting yesterday
quote every family member of Herschel
Walker asked him not to run for office
because we all knew some of his past
every single one he decided to give us
the middle finger and air out all of his
dirty laundry in public while
simultaneously lying about it continuing
I know my mom and I would really
appreciate if my father Herschel Walker
stopped lying and making a mockery of us
you're not a family man when you left us
to bang a bunch of women threatened to
kill us and had us move over six times
in six months running from your violence
I don't care about someone who has a bad
past and takes accountability but how
dare you lie and act as though you're
some moral Christian upright man you've
lived a life of destroying other
people's lives
how dare you
that's Herschel Walker's son and this is
not about getting in the middle of what
is an obvious family problem
this is about the disgusting dishonesty
and hypocrisy of Herschel Walker framing
himself to the Republican Mega nuts of
Georgia as the Christian guy
as the moral guy as the pro-life guy
whatever
and being the complete and total
opposite the only question that remains
and I don't have the answer to this we
it's a it's a question it's a predictive
question we will see in November is we
know what happened after the Trump
Access Hollywood tape
nothing he was elected president of the
United States
are the Georgia Republican voters going
to look away again because they just
really don't like Democrats like Raphael
Warnock
um or is this going to Doom Herschel
Walker's campaign let me know what you
think and all of these clips we've
played we will have on our Instagram
which you can find at davidpackman show
one of our longtime sponsors is monk
pack offering low sugar plant-based keto
friendly bars I love these they are the
perfect snack for anyone trying to eat
better or cutting back on sugar and
carbs without sacrificing taste monk
pack offers granola bars and nut and
Seed bars each with only one gram of
sugar or less two to three net carbs and
150 calories or less I'm a big fan of
the macadamia white chocolate nut and
Seed bar great combination of sweet
salty chewy and crunchy and there's
under one gram of sugar they come in
other awesome flavors like sea salt dark
chocolate coconut cocoa chip and caramel
sea salt monk pack is great if you're
doing keto I don't do keto but monk pack
is just great for anyone who wants
something delicious On The Go without
the sugar and my audience gets 20 off
your first order at monk pack Com when
you use the coupon code Pacman at
checkout the link is down below